[Music]
in a major moment for the modern voting
rights fight house democrats unveiled a
long awaited john lewis voting rights
bill aimed at restoring the voting
rights act of 1965. alabama
representative terry sewell announced
the bill in front of the historic edmund
petters bridge the site where during the
1965 march to montgomery selma police
brutally beat lewis and martin luther
king jr and his fellow marchers in what
became known as bloody sunday
as many of you know
the voting rights act of 1965
was only made possible because of the
personal sacrifices of amazing foot
soldiers many known and unknown
right here on this bridge in my hometown
56 years ago on bloody sunday as john
lewis would say
he shed a little blood on this bridge
for the equal right to vote for all
americans
the bill to protect and restore voting
rights under siege in many republican
control legislators across the country
is set to pass in the
democratic-controlled house of
representatives but it's almost certain
to fail in the senate where it will not
pass the 60-vote threshold to break a
republican filibuster all the same the
push from politicians activists and even
actors is on including from the cw's new
initiative called freedom to vote
featuring their biggest stars i talked
to one of those stars elizabeth tullock
about her and her fellow actors efforts
to protect voter rights
betsy thanks so much for joining me on
the show this evening why did you decide
to take part in this psa video from the
cw network why is it so important to you
to speak out about voting rights right
now
i would say that uh democracy is sort of
under attack right now because there has
been a slew of voter suppression laws
that are either being introduced as
bills or straight up being past and
state legislatures all over the country
and there's nothing more important than
protecting
voting rights and ensuring that
everybody can participate participate
freely and also have the right to
fair access to cast those votes safely
and easily so i find what's going on
pretty frightening um this the cw's
freedom to
vote campaign is nonpartisan
and
i guess earlier this month on the 56th
anniversary of the john lewis passage of
the voting rights act they decided to to
start this campaign to encourage
congress to protect voting rights
yeah it's weird we live in a country
where suddenly protecting democracy
small d democracy is a partisan issue
that should be something we all agree on
wherever we are on the political
spectrum but as you say it's frightening
what's going on right now i wonder
though what i'm glad you guys are
speaking out
what about the argument from some on the
right that celebrities actors sports
stars should stay out of politics keep
their views to themselves or as fox's
laura ingram famously said in response
to lebron james shut up and
dribble would say that uh
the right to disagree is fundamentally
an american right and whether we
disagree about reproductive freedom or
climate change my voice is just as
important that it be heard as anybody
else's
and um i i personally feel that if you
have a platform to do
to to do good like do it and use it if
you feel comfortable with doing that and
again this is a nonpartisan campaign
we're all we're saying the message is
really simple we all deserve the right
to vote and everybody's voice should be
heard equally
yes well said just on voting rights in
american democracy you mentioned the the
john lewis voting rights act you met the
late congressman john lewis i believe
out of all places san diego comic con in
2016. uh there's a picture of you here
with him and your fellow actor russell
hornsby what was that like and what do
you make of the john lewis voting rights
act currently stuck in congress like
before the people act too
uh that was really uh
honestly overwhelming i was out to
dinner at this comic con in 2016. he was
there promoting his graphic novel march
and i saw him walk into the restaurant
and i almost started shaking because
he's such a civil rights icon and i i
talked to my co-star russell and i said
i'm never going to forgive myself if i
don't introduce myself and just thank
him for everything he's done for this
country and so he went up to him and
took a picture he's incredibly gracious
um i think it's very important
it is critical that the john lewis
voting rights advancement act is passed
um
because you know what happened in 2013
with the supreme court gunning certain
provisions like that of pre-clearance
all of that needs to be reinstated
pre-clearance is particularly important
because it ensured that jurisdictions
that had a history of discriminating
discriminating against voters of color
were required to have any changes to
their voting rules approved by the
federal government so we need federal
legislation to protect everyone um and
again what what we're already starting
to see since the 2020 election is
frightening and i read some statistics
that since june 2021 i think 17 states
have actually enacted laws with
restrictive provisions and so it is
really important to have some federal
oversight
definitely uh let's see what congress is
gonna do we've been uh covering it
heavily on this show we can only wait
and see and see if it ever gets through
the senate and this filibuster's ever
dealt with let me ask you this bitsy
have you always been a political person
interested in politics or did the trump
era radicalize you like it radicalized
so many otherwise previously a political
people in hollywood
it's a really good question i would i've
certainly never been apolitical um i've
always been somebody who wanted to use
my voice for good when i graduated from
college one of my very first jobs was
working as an assistant and researcher
for patrick cadell who was a democratic
pollster
um and so that was getting thrown into
fire we worked on um a bunch of stuff
together and uh but 100 i would say what
started happening in 2015 and 2016 with
trump um
ascension into power
absolutely that galvanized me more to
get even more political and to use my
platform in a way that can sometimes
feel scary because i come under a lot of
fire as i'm sure do other celebrities
who are using their voice and in ways
that not all of their fans agree with
and they get angry but um i don't know
that i could really look myself in the
face if i had an opportunity to speak up
and it didn't
so you mentioned your fans you mentioned
being an actor you're currently on the
cw playing one of the most iconic
on-screen journalists ever lois lane
giving some phenomenal performances
following in the footsteps of you know
margo donna terry hatcher what is it
like to play lois lane this legendary
journalist and what do you think some of
us real life journalists could learn
from her
just to uh
the thing that's the coolest thing about
her is just how entirely uncompromising
and unafraid she was abusing her voice
and
um i was originally cast in 2018 and
just seeing how
you know with this whole fake news and
the media is the enemy and everything
that's been popping up in the last few
years just the importance of
uh staying committed to
to truth and staying committed to um
[Music]
you know
just being truthful and
lois lane embodies this
more than any other
character and she is probably you know
one of us not the most famous
journalists on that we've seen on screen
and so it's been a
very humbling to be playing her at a
time when the profession of journalism
has come under siege especially in the
last few years
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show by
clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date on the day's biggest
stories thank you for watching